hey if you want to support more content
on this channel and also get some sweet
anime merge check out anime ah procom we
have original exclusive designs by pro
artist Cuusoo midi like this Eskin or
praise the sun shirt link in the
description
[Music]
what up guys goes in here for anime
uproar and I thought it would be cool if
for this video I looked at every power
level in seven deadly sins since I know
how much you guys like seeing how
characters in the show stack up to
others in terms of strength so I have
reread the manga and we will go through
every single power level or if you
prefer combat class that is revealed in
the manga within the main story and
within other special manga materials fYI
I will use combat class and power level
interchangeably throughout this video if
you want the 7 deadly sins to keep on
coming fingers stab that like button and
subscribe and ring that magic YouTube
Bell so Merlin will transport future
seven deadly sins videos right to your
handheld device don't forget to suggest
future videos in the comments that your
burn enough to see keep in mind that
I'll be going past word the anime
currently is so if you want know manga
spoilers you've been warned now let us
begin
so let's mention how combat class was
first introduced to the series in volume
14 page 28 of the manga hawk reads holy
night platinum de Gaydos power he has a
290 in magic a 470 in force which is
sometimes also called strength and a 100
in spirit making his total combat class
of 860 the first that was introduced in
the manga series hawk is able to see it
because Merlin gave Hawk BAE Laura's
magical eye to wear as an earring the
name comes from the name of the one-eyed
God a misfortune who could see through
his enemy's balers eye allows Hawk to
see everyone's score in magic force and
spirit and also their total combat class
which as Merlin explains is the
numerical value given to your targets
genuine strength the magic score stands
for magical power the forest score
stands for physical strength and spirit
stands for composure and perseverance in
a fight we learned shortly after that
Gotha is also equipped with veil or zai
and he points out that combat class is
at best a rough estimate and that its
value can shift by a myriad of
conditions compatibilities and
circumstances it won't always decide who
wins fights or
example someone could lie in front of
gallon and be turned to stone so they
could theoretically still lose the match
even if they have a higher combat class
than him that's just a quick warning
that combat class isn't everything but
like power levels in Dragon Ball
it is extremely fun to know and compare
different combat classes so that's why
we're going to go over every single one
i will go from weakest to strongest and
not in the order that they are
introduced in the manga the reason for
this is I don't want you guys to have to
go back and compare which characters
were stronger than which other ones this
way you'll know exactly where every
power level stands in respect to the
others ready set let's go the weakest
power level recorded as far as I could
find was Eska Norris nighttime form
which was a 15-5 and magic five in
strength and five in spirit he is
followed up by Hawkes base power level
which is a thirty zero in magic a twenty
five in strength and a five in spirit
next up we have some random Knights that
Hawk spotted as soon as he was given the
power to read power levels the Knights
had power levels ranging from 35 to 145
so that will put some of the future
power levels in perspective if even a
person with a power level of 35 can
become a knight
Veronica has a power level of 80 while
Margaret has a power level of 110 the
white demons have power levels ranging
from 150 to 250 at 190 we have the sand
crawler version of hawk as we can see
his power can grow when he uses his
transport ability and it can grow
significantly if he eats even stronger
creatures in Chapter 169 Jericho's power
level is measured to be 280 which is
just shy of the holy night cutoff point
which usually requires a minimum power
level of 300 however power levels can
fluctuate as we've seen throughout the
series
so Jericho can potentially grow her
power level to be over 300 even without
the help of demon blood cobalt demons
range from 400 to 1,300 ruin of the
weird things as a parallel of 420 while
freesias of the weird fangs has a power
level of 400
forty they are both considered to be
top-quality Warriors then we have the
king of Leona's himself at 530 green
demons vary from 600 to 900 now again we
have hawk his tyrant dragon transport
keishon has a power level of 610 the
ocher demons vary from 800 to 1100 as
mentioned the Platinum holy night and
member of the plainest of the azure sky
dog a doe has a power level of eight
hundred and sixty one of his teammates
del dree has a power level of 930 the
red demons vary from 1000 to 1300 the
red demon version of hawk scored a 1030
which is quite an impressive improvement
from his base power level of 30 so even
Hawk has the potential with transport to
become stronger than many high-ranking
holy Knights put together Dale the
father of gila and zeal originally has a
power level of 1220 the persimmon demons
also known as the Koala demons have a
power level ranging from 1,300 to 1,600
ardan another member of denzel's Azur
sky has a power level of 1320 gila comes
in above her father at 1350 pilgrim
king's best friend has a power level of
1400 gree amore when first measured has
a power level of 1520 Theo the druid
priest has a power level of 1650 diamond
holy night death peers another member of
denzel's team comes in at 1690 mod a
royal member of the vampire clan who
played a part in the side story vampires
of edinburgh comes in at 1700 Dan's
elves holy night while OU has a power
level of 1710 Gani is mods vampire
brother and his power level is 1720 when
he was first measured Hauser's power
level was 1910 in volume 17 of the manga
naka bud the mangaka reveals into
question corner that Elizabeth's power
level is 1925 broken down she got 1700
magic five in strength and 220 in spirit
Gill's first measured power levels 1970
then after his training in ISTAR it
jumped to two thousand three hundred and
thirty Hauser although he originally has
a lower power level than Gil jumps to
two thousand three hundred and fifty
after the training in East our green
more a doe is turned to a kid by a
magical creature and he is actually the
only one to temporarily become weaker
after his training he goes from a power
level of 1520 to a power level of 410 at
two thousand three hundred and seventy
we have get hey Adi the sister of the
first fairy King after that we had Dale
with red demon blood whose power level
was two thousand four hundred and ninety
which is actually more than double his
original power but he loses access to
his original magic powers next we have
Vivian the former apprentice of Merlin
and obsessive fangirl of guilt under she
is referred to as the strongest mage of
Leonys after Merlin and her power level
is an impressive two thousand five
hundred and eighty above Vivian we have
Hendrickson in his human form with the
power level of two thousand six hundred
and fifty the gray or ash demons vary
from two thousand seven hundred to three
thousand two hundred slater the captain
of dawn roar has a power level of two
thousand seven hundred and ninety coming
up next we have Elaine's power level
before she sprouts fully grown wings
which is two thousand eight hundred and
thirty then we have Denzel Leonys
younger brother of the king and captain
of the azure sky team he has a power
level of two thousand eight hundred and
seventy three thousand is what hawk at
first believes his power level to be
because when telling him his power level
Merlin multiplies his power by 100
however characters who do actually have
a power level of 3000 include great holy
night Dreyfuss and the two former
members of the goddess clan Jenna and
Sunehri great holy night seductress
father of guilt under has a power level
of 3060 next we have the seven deadly
sins his own go third when he's first
measured he has a power level of 3100
broken down he scored a 1300 and magic a
500 in strength and
1300 and spirit also at 3100 we got red
who looks like vampire Deanne and/or
laundy another vampire royal who went on
to become a flying eye that assists
Merlin pawns power level was measured at
three thousand two hundred and twenty
which breaks down into 1380 in magic 930
and strength and 910 in spirit dn when
first measured has a power level of
three thousand two hundred and fifty
which is made up of nine hundred and
magic 1870 and strength and four hundred
eighty in spirit Mele ODIs when first
measured has a power level of three
thousand three hundred and seventy which
can be broken down into a four hundred
of magic a nine hundred sixty and
strength and an impressive 2010 in
spirit gelda is another vampire but not
the last vampire on this list
she is zelgius 'as lover and her power
level four thousand eighty is definitely
nothing to sneeze at above her we got
King with his first measured power level
which was 4190 during his fight against
GLE and the demon mark appears on Mellie
Otis and his power level jumps to four
thousand four hundred which is still not
enough to defeat the LAN Merlin's power
level when first measured is 4710
scoring a crazy 3540 in magic a 70 in
strength and a 1100 spirit near the
beginning of the series Merlins magic
alone is higher than the total power
level of many of the sins which is crazy
to think about next up we have the last
vampire from the vampires of Edinburgh
side story
the vampire king himself Ezra vampire
King Ezra according to Merlin had a
power level of 4890 and Eska nor could
defeat him by simply standing close to
him the heat emanating from Eska Knorr
body is enough to completely overpower
such a strong opponent which boys
towards Eska Knorr insane power but more
on that later
next we have the great beast Albion's
which are giant and powerful golems that
were created by the demon clan every
single Albion has a power level of 5500
as 5800 we have Hendrickson after he has
been mutated
by the blood of a great demon he was the
main bad guy if you will of the first
season
so although the power levels will get
much higher than this it's important to
keep in mind that he gave his seven
deadly sins plenty of trouble at the
time Matrona the leader of the giant
clan had a bigger power level than I
expected at 7600 D an after her journey
back in time with King and her
subsequent power up has a base power
level of 8,000 but can raise it a lot
through dancing jumping to a power level
of ten thousand and ten we have Arthur's
cat thing called calf where was this
overpowered pet cat in season one he
could have saved the gang a lot of
trouble
Mellie Otis during the a fermented
battle against Galan reaches a power
level of ten thousand three hundred his
demon mark grows to cover almost half of
his face and his demon power is
overflowing but it is still not enough
to win keep in mind at this point
Mellie Otis still hasn't received the
part of his power that Merlin sealed
away in his star in volume 27 go through
attempts to run away from the end
because he doesn't want his memories
back
DeeAnn dances and grows her power level
to 15100 in this way while explaining
that she can grow her power even more if
she keeps dancing next up we have Elaine
with fully grown wings she has a power
level of twenty one thousand and fifty
and it was said that her feelings for
bond the one she loves made her bodies
stronger then drained of all his magic
gallons power level was nonetheless
measured at 26,000 gallons only has some
one thousand in magic though so fully
charged he is twenty-seven thousand and
we'll get to his critical / mode in a
bit at twenty eight thousand is esken or
yet again this was actually quite an
interesting situation go through uses
his power and has Eskin or think of
Merlin during the night and he
transforms into his daytime form saying
that Merlin is the very Sun itself in
this form he launches an attack that
actually does considerable damage to the
unprepared role and gloxinia this
situation also suggests that we may see
Eskin or use his daytime form in the
future even in situations where the
actual Sun is nowhere in sight at 31,000
is the
of selflessness broderick Mellie Otis
after he receives the powers that Merlin
sealed away in istar has a resting power
level of thirty two thousand five
hundred Mille ask allah the commandment
of faith is next in the list with a
power level of thirty four thousand
after Dan succeeds in chasing him down
and Gotha regains his memories his own
power level shoots up to thirty five
thousand four hundred gray Road the
commandment of pacifism has a power
level of thirty nine thousand then
gallons critical overcomes in where his
power level grows to forty thousand but
still he is no match for near noon s
kannur tied with gallons in his critical
/ mode is actually our third Arthur's
power level is also forty thousand
believe it or not he got a thirty seven
thousand six hundred and magic a nine
hundred and strength in a 1,500 and
spirit and I thought Merlin had a good
score in magic but Arthur's magic score
is absolutely insane when he finally
awakens to his powers we can definitely
expect great things from him King after
travelling back in time in his
subsequent powerup as a power level of
forty 1600 next we have the an possessed
by an eddy by raising her power level
through dancing dee Eddie is able to
push the Ann's power level up to 48,000
and according to the guidebook dee Ann
can go up even further to fifty thousand
a power level of fifty thousand is an
important cutoff point for demons
because demons with a power level of
fifty thousand or more can complete and
Endora transformation by sacrificing six
of their seven hearts after this
transformation the demon gains a huge
power boost but they sacrificed their
ability to reason along with their six
hearts Derry area with her power level
of 52,000 and won't speed with his power
level of 53,000 both qualified for the
indirect transformation and underwent it
afterwards they easily took out the
Archangel sorry l and Tarmey L and had a
clear upper hand against Luna shell
before Elizabeth the goddess reverted
them back into their normal forms Ludo
shall at the very least had a power
level over two hundred thousand at this
point so you can imagine just how
drastically this transformation can
increase
the power levels of demons if Meli
oldest would undergo such a
transformation
it might also increase his power by more
than four times which is crazy to think
about next we have troll the giant king
who has a power level of fifty four
thousand after he is brought back from
the dead because of the curse Mele Otis
has a power level of sixty thousand he
easily destroys fraud room and Merlin
explains that he's even stronger in his
demon form the guidebook places Esther
OSes power level at 60,000 and zelgius
power level at 61 thousand Esther OSA
powers up to eighty eight thousand after
he absorbs gallons commandments then
there's Eskin or again at 114 thousand
he hits this power level as it is
nearing noon and Mellie Otis in assault
mode also called annihilation mode still
has no problem overpowering him at this
level
although when s Kannur enters the one
mode it's a different story in vol 29 of
the manga Mellie Otis's power level in
assault mode is set to be one hundred
forty two thousand and yet s Kannur in
his the one mode takes him out with one
movement of his hand
demon coup sock aka sell dresses teacher
has a power level of one hundred sixty
eight thousand while demon Chandler a
game le Otis's teacher has a power level
of one hundred and seventy three
thousand and those power levels are
before Chandler casts the spell of
darkness which blocks out the Sun in the
night time according to Chandler the
power level of demons increase all the
more so Chandler and Cusack should be
stronger than their previously mentioned
power levels after Chandler uses his
darkness fell we know that looter Shelly
Margaret's body has a power level of two
hundred and one thousand the largest
specific power level we've been given so
far and we also know that mile after he
absorbs four commandments has a more
vague power level of over two hundred
thousand now Esther OSA who turns out to
be my ELF is a very interesting case
because we got to see how his power
levels grew after he absorbed additional
commandments because of that fans have
tried to use that information to get an
idea of the demon Kings power level in
chapter 247 it is said that the demon
king split his own power in two and then
split the second half into
and fragments each of which became one
of the ten commandments and was given to
a chosen warrior thus if we assume that
each of these ten commandments are equal
and represent a certain power level we
can begin to get an idea of the demon
Kings power esther osa gained gallons
commandment and his power level rose by
twenty eight thousand from 60,000 to 88
thousand that would suggest that one
commandment represents a power level of
twenty eight thousand times that by 10
you get two hundred eighty thousand
times that by two you get five hundred
and sixty thousand if this were the case
the demon Kings power level when he
split this power would have been five
hundred and sixty thousand currently it
would be half of that in other words two
hundred eighty thousand plus any power
increase he may have received from
absorbing energy in purgatory for all
these years - whatever
extra power he may be lending to zelgius
so we can't know for sure what his
current power level is but like I said
some fans assumed that at some point it
was five hundred sixty thousand because
of the power increase after Esther osa
absorbed gallons commandment now this is
seemingly contradicted when after
absorbing two more Commandments Esther
OSes power level jumps up not to 144,000
as you'd expect if you believe in this
theory but to over two hundred thousand
so there are some possible explanations
for this perhaps the ten fragments are
not equal at all and represent different
amounts of power perhaps the demon king
would give higher amounts of power to
people that he trusts more like his own
sons eldress another explanation could
be that the power was in fact split into
10 equal fragments and Esther osis power
level would have climbed to 144,000 if
it was not for him regaining his
memories of being my L as with Gotha it
is possible that the additional power
boost happened because my al started to
regain his memories so he got access to
his old goddess powers that he had lost
or buried during the time he spent
believing he was the demon king's son
then again perhaps the demon Kings power
is more than the sum of its parts and
when more of it comes together it
doesn't just add up but increases the
individuals
are exponentially let me know what you
think in the comments or if you have any
other ideas about the demon Kings power
level so this video we have looked at
the power levels that we were clearly
given unfortunately many power levels
including the demon Kings power level
we're not given and as a result we have
to make educated guesses about that we
can assume that King with his full grown
wings is now well over 200,000 because
he was able to overpower mile with four
Commandments easily in this form and we
know that mile at this point has a
combat class over 200,000 we also know
that many other characters are overdue
for a new power level reading like
Vaughan who has spent so much time
adapting to the harsh conditions of
purgatory and Merlin whose last reading
was four thousand seven hundred and ten
and yet in Chapter 291 she was seemingly
able to defeat Cusack and Chandler who
both have ridiculously high power levels
one hundred sixty eight thousand and one
hundred seventy three thousand
respectively and that's before any
nighttime power boost they may receive I
know that it's not all about power
levels and you can outsmart your
opponents too but there's just no way
that the current Merlin with her opie
magical ability infinity should stay at
a four-digit power level we also know
that Melly Otis who was able to reach a
power level of 140 mm in his assault
mode is now in the process of absorbing
five Commandments if for the fun of it
we assume that each one of those
Commandments represents at least a power
level of twenty eight thousand which is
a conservative estimate in my view then
Mel Yoda should increase his power level
by 140 thousand which would give him a
power level in assault mode of at least
two hundred eighty two thousand combined
that with the fact that he'll have
access to his original power which she
hasn't been using up to this point and
you can bet he's going to be able to
crush almost every character that we've
seen so far and that is using a
conservative estimate that doesn't count
on the exponential style of power
increase that we saw in my L or R the
possibility that he could be absorbing
power fragments of the demon king that
are individually larger than 28-thousand
also this is assuming
he doesn't get even more Commandments
because his plan is to absorb all ten so
yeah if you thought malleolus was Opie
before just wait for the upcoming
chapters but then there's also another
interesting idea to consider what does
the manga mean exactly when it says
stuff like beyond measure or invincible
for instance in volume 15 on page 149 we
are given a bonus page in the manga that
is not part of the main story but gives
us extra information about the world of
the seven deadly sins on this page we
are told that there was an example of
mutated species of grey demon existing
in the past with a combat class beyond
measure no other details are known and
quote Eskin or speak power at noon is
also said to be unmeasurable since we
were able to measure combat classes over
two hundred thousand so far
what does beyond measure mean this is
just a way of saying very strong is it a
way of saying infinite or is there a
certain arbitrary point at strength
where combat class can no longer be
measured for instance after a million
you can no longer see exact numbers or
something like that let me know what you
think in the comments I am very curious
about the case of s Kannur and his Dewan
form this form is explained in the manga
as follows for just one minute he
becomes the invincible incarnation of
power the one for that one minute when
the Sun is at its highest point
we never got an exact reading of s
canora's power level but it is said that
he's invincible again can we take this
literally and assume his power is
limitless and unbeatable or is it just a
way of saying he's really really strong
it's an interesting question because so
far the one has been able to defeat
every opponent he's come up against with
his bare hand
but would he stand a chance against the
goddess or the demon king in that one
minute I really hope we get to see that
kind of matchup in the future if there
is a limit to the demon Kings power even
if that limit is over 1 million could an
invincible opponent who is said to have
a power level that cannot be measured
like Eskin or in the one form defeat him
of course in this hypothetical situation
the demon king does not have his special
ability the ruler activated which would
reverse all damage and turn
into healing and fortification instead
again let me know what you think in the
comments it all depends how seriously
you take words like invincible and what
is meant by a power that is beyond
measure but I'll just say it's funny how
this list ended up being an s Kannur
sandwich with other characters stuck in
between his knight form is on the bottom
as the weakest power level and his
strongest form is potentially at the top
of this list being simultaneously the
weakest and strongest is quite the rare
feat anyways that's it for today's video
thanks so much for watching I really
appreciate it
I hope you had fun going over all of the
power levels that we've seen so far in
the manga and speculating about the
power levels that we haven't seen yet if
you want to share an ESCO Norse
invincible unmeasurable glory you can
buy our praise the Sun Eskin or shirt
link to that in the description or you
can just go to anime out Broadcom we pay
professional manga artist Kazuma D to
design this original shirt for us and
fellow fans of seven deadly sins so
definitely check it out if you're
interested for fans of the channel you
can even get 25% off by using the code
uproar 25 at checkout anyways I really
enjoyed making this video I personally
love looking at power levels even if
sometimes the writers don't take them
too seriously themselves if you enjoyed
the video make sure to raise the
glorious divine axe Rita and smash down
on that like button with it also if you
haven't subscribed and bring that magic
YouTube Belle and Merlyn will teleport
new 7 Deadly Sins videos straight to
your phone thanks again for watching and
until next time see us space cowboy
[Music]
you